I think the greatest threat and the
greatest concern certainly for the
Royals is the force coming autobiography
the autobiography by Prince Harry and
which is of course caused a lot of
consternation in Royal circles a lot of
concern amongst senior Royal sources and
and Palisades because quite simply they
don't know what to expect there's a lot
of rumors that Prince Harry is making
possibly last minute edits to the book
is edited to the Queen's death well the
The Queen's death and also in light of
the Queen's death the sensitivity
perhaps of some of the passages that
he's written about and so the
autobiography has been shouted in
secrecy and I think it is a case of
belts and braces and the palace really
preparing themselves for what's to come
because Harry has taken a 35 million
dollar advance the chances of him
handing that back and saying actually
I'm not going to do this book after all
I think that's highly unlikely yeah and
35 million dollars I would think that
kind of money talks and they would want
Harry to talk specifics about their
Royals and given that sum of money right
yeah I think I think you're absolutely
right when you're having that sort of an
advance that's not going to be for Harry
talking about his philanthropic work
right that's going to be the inside
story of being born the spare what it
entailed I mean I've sat down with with
Harry before and he said to me you know
there are many times I wish I wasn't
born a prince it was very apparent to me
early on that he actually wanted a way
out you know the the vision of the
palace for him to be William's sidekick
his wingman all these years actually
perhaps wasn't always Harry's vision and
I think it's you know Megan's been
blamed for the rift at the heart of
Windsor and for megsit but actually you
know was she just the Catalyst that
Harry needed to get out I think we're
going to see him shed a lot of light on
why he left in this new book interesting
I cannot wait for that read for sure
[Music]
thank you